foreign
down here it's sad to say but that's
kind of what people are calling us and
we're calling ourselves that
quality of life standards are just
diminishing literally like this our
crime was at its lowest 50 years in
2019. 50 year low now we're murder
capital of the nation
women are inside after dark we've had
women who've actually put up videos
about it we posted some on manolatoya
recall uh Instagram Facebook and Twitter
the city's out of control because it's
crime everywhere I'm scared to leave my
house
women are scared you know they go with
their husbands their boyfriends or you
know cousins or someone just to go get
gas or to go to the grocery store or run
me or I got to be inside before it's
dark uh yeah we're scared and
unfortunately we don't want to live like
this anymore and we're taking our city
back we just want
um not to have to
feel
feel safe just sitting at a red light
you know somebody was shot sitting at a
red light
driving on I-10 people are scared people
are fearful we have an administration of
intimidation and fear tactics they will
they will take your job they will take
your livelihood they will and they don't
care
um and we're tired of it you know we're
tired of living under that oppression
new orleanians we are we're pretty
resilient and honestly we're tired of
being resilient we want to thrive you
know we've been resilient since Betty
Katrina Ida you can go through the
hurricanes in between we're tired we
don't we don't want to be resilient
anymore we want to thrive and we deserve
that
thank you